salve ora essere alla fine sempre
mostrato
ho pensato di cominciare in un certo
modo poi in realtà ho sentito due
persone citare laddove iniziato il mio
viaggio nella resilienza abbiamo parlato
di johan rockstrom stato citato da
giulia sventola riccarda a digitate lo
ior rockstrom era il mio direttore non
lo sto come bar menti institute e da lì
è cominciato il mio viaggio nel 2008
probabilmente quel viaggio di ritorno
sono i cervelli in fuga anche un è un
termine meraviglioso sono anche i
cervelli di rientro e quando sono
rientrato in italia nel viaggio ricordo
che pensavo e ti ho imparato una parola
nuova mentre stava in estonia è la prima
nuova la resilienza avevo in mente cosa
era il significato la resilienza e avevo
anche in mente uno schema che è quello
che trovate qua dietro questo che a
guardarlo 1 lì viene il panico dice come
faccio a spiegare cos'è la resilienza
eppure in questa in questo grafico si
nota quello che è la resilienza in tutti
i suoi legami adesso andiamo a cercare
di capire come come funziona la
resilienza la resilienza dei significati
che vengono applicati in diversi domini
della nostra vita
c'era la scienza dei materiali e gli
ingegneri lo sanno bene di solito si
descrive molto bene con la mensola
quando si carica una mensola di libri
noi la quando la misura si piega quando
liberiamo dai libri la messa la torna
quasi allo stato iniziale non è però lo
stesso stato iniziale quella energia che
si libera e la residenza dei materiali
abbiamo la resilienza nelle scienze
naturali che sono gli ecosistemi io di
solito quando tempo più tempo del tempo
di un fed
parlo di solito che quello che è
successo nel pop con queste carte
gigantesche la settimana scorsa aveva
pescato una da 3 metri ad esempio quella
carta gaga hanno pescato all'inizio era
un animale esterno all'ecosistema negli
anni poi si è adattato l'ecosistema è
stato un percorso di resilienza e ha
pure si genera ancora dei problemi dei
disturbi oggi è parte integrante
dell'ecosistema l'abbiamo in psicologia
che forse è la cosa più bella che
abbiamo della resilienza in psicologia
in psicologia e la capacità degli umani
di reagire a uno shock di solito dicono
sempre un po a tutti noi è successo di
essere lasciati dalla compagnia della
compagna o di aver perso una persona
cara e quando dobbiamo recuperare dopo
questo trauma impieghiamo del tempo però
attiviamo anche delle capacità che sono
nostre interne sono quelle capacità
residenti che è
mi affido alla famiglia cominciano a
fare qualcosa che comincia a correre ad
esempio ho l'obiettivo di andare fra
martina di new york
oppure c'è chi si affida a fare nuove
attività semplicemente e pensate che dal
secondo dopoguerra ad oggi siamo
riusciti a risolvere 13 casi di malattie
mentali
grazie alla residenza in psicologia ma
perché perché presidente psicologia non
va più a confinare il problema ma
identifica il problema lo riconosce e
poi da l'edificazione l'assunzione di
responsabilità di dire a un problema
comincia a lavorare sulla risposta
quindi non mi fermo a discutere e questo
è molto tipico italiano
io ho un sogno quando alle stasera a
bere una birra con gli amici entrare in
un bar e sentire tutte le persone entro
un bar parlare delle soluzioni per far
ripartire il paese invece quando entri
non presenti tutti che parlano di
problemi abbiamo una marea di problemi
continuiamo a ripeterci tra di noi che
questo sapeste sia in 60 anni abbiamo
sempre gli stessi problemi nel clima
parliamo di sesso idrogeologico su 60
anni è sempre la stessa discussione
viene giù la montagna lo sappiamo che
viene giù la montagna nelle prime
esperienze di questo viaggio cominciato
questo percorso in italia sulla
resilienza una delle prime battute mi
facevano le persone diciamo ma cos'è la
residenza è un cocktail o come un corte
ebbene in questo viaggio ho scoperto di
un esigenza e un cocktail può essere
anche un cocktail sono arrivato in un
bar a vicenza dove c'è giacomo diamante
che questo bar tender che si è inventato
un nuovo lavoro dove l'alcol non è più
solo una bevanda ma alcune una storia è
un racconto si parla della prima donna a
rizzi casata bartender ad esempio che è
un racconto molto bello che lui fa
peccato un simbolo che ha interrotto ha
creato quello che si chiama me ne vorrà
adesso giacomo il ticket bar che sono i
bardi del proibizionismo americano l'ha
creato a vicenza e dentro creato un
nuovo modo di vivere il bar decide che
non ci vuole dentro e in questo percorso
la prima volta che entrò mi chiede di
non hai il menu entra in dice una parola
quello che vuoi vuoi un piero pellizzaro
io ovviamente essendo un po malato di
resilienza e le ho detto vogliono
resilienza e lui mi guarda e mi dice ma
dove legge ha bevuto da nessuna parte
perché è venuto un imprenditore due
settimane fa abbiamo inventato un
cocktail e questo imprenditore l'ha
chiamato resilienza
perché è quello che lui sta facendo
nella sua azienda è un'azienda residente
un'azienda che nella crisi non si ferma
ma trova una sfida e da questa sfida
tira fuori qualcosa di nuovo di
innovativo per giacomo la resilienza e
la capacità di creare un gusto nuovo un
giusto equilibrio tra quello che la
reazione le reazioni e le emozioni che
un cocktail può dare creando nuovi
sapori perché c'è un periodo di choc
questo per correttezza è un altro
resilienza non è quello che mi ha fatto
già come quella sera hanno bevuto a
marja loca a parigi e questo è molto
bello perché si è composto da tre parti
la parte sopra che è frutto della
passione svuotato dentro un rum che a 70
gradi che ti crea lo shock prima di
berlo e per una parte dolce una parte
bitter perché anche nel processo di
resilienza successiva c'è una parte di
meraviglia quando riesce a dire ho
superato ma poi c'è una parte anche
difficile che è quella della ricaduta
perché c'è sempre una ricaduta non c'è
mai una soluzione definitiva
l'adattamento e continuo perché la
natura e dinamica e questo lo insegna la
residenza che è diversa della
sostenibilità che alla fine trova un
punto di equilibrio si cerca di trovare
invece oggi noi abbiamo città diverse
poi nel mio viaggio scoperto che c'è una
pizzeria residenza e a salerno e generò
cassetto la resilienza capacità di
creare un giusto equilibrio tra la
natura e la sua capacità di produrre
prodotti genuini senza subire
contaminazioni esterne alimentazione
immaginare una storia diversa anche era
stato un ristorante prima un ristorante
che è stato come dire danneggiato a
salerno questa pizzeria non si ferma
dice no io non mi faccio intimorire vado
avanti un'italia che reagisce e non solo
fa un nuovo ristorante ma crea un nuovo
legame col territorio utilizza solo
prodotti locali pieni prezzi bassi ma
valorizzando i prodotti sostenibili del
territorio quindi anche nell'equilibrio
in questo e creano chiama resilienza che
non bella iniziativa dire che queste
fossero più bella che ho visto anche poi
un certo punto mi batto io sia fantomas
è un rapper canti pop rap italiano e
messinese e in una canzone si chiama
resilienza e lui dice questo è citato
testualmente il suo testo la residenza è
sempre stata un'esigenza vitale per lui
per altri solo un modo per fare soldi ad
abbaiare il mi sono sentito coinvolto
avevo paura di questo
sicilia messina la mia terra guerriera
ripassati la storia poi parliamo fino a
sera e parla di messina in questa
canzone della sua terra una terra che ha
sempre reagito alle difficoltà e che
oggi nelle difficoltà trova sempre uno
spunto se mi chiedete qual è la città
più residente in italia io vi rispondo
che a palermo perché palermo ha una sua
capacità intrinseca di valorizzare le
reti locali i valori e dare risposta
anche meta organizzati di dare risposte
al disagio e le difficoltà sociali che
sono presenti nella città insieme mai
separati e quella quella che noi
chiamiamo disordine in realtà un ordine
resiliente delle cose poi sono arrivato
a barre
ho messo vicino scampia per per la
medicazione me ne vogliano delteatro.it
ball perché so che non vogliono che si
faccia questa questa affiancamento
neanche barra non è scampia però a barra
hanno fatto il carnevale a residente e
cos'è che voglio ma il credente o meglio
da chi è fatto il carnevale resilienti
che ma nel residenti è fatto da giovani
tendenzialmente giovani che hanno perso
i genitori per camorra o che comunque
sono vicini a famiglie
tendenzialmente area grosso rischio di
infiltrazione camorristica e loro li
coinvolgono attraverso giochi di strada
arte di strada gli ridanno un sorriso li
danno un opportunità e ogni anno creano
questo carnevale resiliente che poi si
diventando itinerante oggi è una
risposta comunitaria a un'emergenza che
non solo del sud italia ma di tutta
l'italia che sono le mafie nel loro
senso più largo e questo si fa porta
resilienza lettera di una comunità con
il sorriso con la psicologia ma col
divertimento come con la rete perché è
una rete di persone poi nella mia vita
ha avuto il piacere di essere parte del
primo progetto di resilienza urbana in
cina in italia abbiamo ottenuto un
finanziamento della commissione europea
è stato fatto un progetto si chiama blu
app v tralascio l'acronimo in inglese lo
dico in italiano bologna citare esigente
e per il comune di bologna la resilienza
è la lotta ai cambiamenti climatici e
l'obiettivo di rendere nel nostro
territorio resiliente non alle emissioni
ma agli impatti perché oggi cambiamento
climatico è in realtà non è più un
qualcosa che avverrà nel 2050 e quindi
per il comune di bologna resilienza
nella capacità di reagire in maniera
tempestiva a fenomeni imprevedibili
quali alluvioni per le siccità e bufere
di neve e quindi come rendere non solo
al mio comune amministrazione ma anche
gli enti e le istituzioni che operano
sul territorio capaci di reagire non
solo di adattarci e quindi di prevenire
in un certo senso ma anche di reagire
perché come dicono spesso un concetto
residente di americani o dice spesso il
presidente obama in questo noi dobbiamo
un certo senso si può operare nella
prevenzione ma anche nella capacità di
risposta di reazione troppo spesso
perdiamo tempo a discutere di quello che
è successo
anziché reagire i colleghi di copenaghen
quando anno parlano della residenza
urbana ti dicono sempre che c'è un game
changer lo chiamano ovvero che è la
capacità è un periodo di tempo sei mesi
dopo uno shock dove hai un forte
coinvolgimento della cittadinanza per
poter rispondere attivare nuove risposte
se noi perdiamo questo game changer
abbiamo perso anche l'opportunità della
sensibilità bisogna poi c'è un gioco
quando faccio queste cose
qualcuno si ricorda cosa è successo nel
2003 a quanti amano se se lo ricorda
black out oltre black out peggio di una
guerra no peggio di una guerra un'ondata
di calore
abbiamo avuto quasi 70.000 morti in
tutta europa e noi non ce lo ricordiamo
abbiamo avuto in un'estate più morti di
una guerra e nessuno se lo ricorda le
ondate di calore sono le evidenze
dell'impatto del cambiamento climatico e
se non diamo risposte a questo noi non
saremo capaci di prevenire e difendere
quelle che non sono soprattutto due
generazioni c'è la generazione più
vecchia in un certo senso che porta così
alla memoria che è una parte fondante
della resilienza e i bambini che sono i
soggetti più deboli che sono il nostro
futuro che la resilienza la memoria e
l'innovazione
perché questa è la residenza una
comunità saper coniugare quello che
sapevamo fare e ammodernandolo con le
nuove innovazioni come sito parlare
prima
dopo di che è successo che la città di
milano ha ottenuto ed è questo il suo
percorso verso la resilienza urbana è un
qualcosa che è iniziato da poco per il
comune di milano nella residenza è
capace di dare risposta con una
sensazione a più fattori di rischi noi
oggi abbiamo sempre abituati nelle città
siamo in un centro bellissimo ma le
nostre periferie
chi se lo ricorda ce ne scordiamo senza
le periferie centri storici non vivono
nelle periferie si affrontano e vivono i
rischi maggiori delle nostre società
per questo il comune di milano dice
addio diversi fattori a un'emergenza
casa dove devo intervenire per dare
risposte all'emergenza casa posso fare
una cosa oltre a rendere più vivibili
quegli spazi per rendere appunto le case
più accessibili più vivibile in un certo
senso posso anche dare una risposta al
cambiamento climatico come lo possiamo
fare possiamo prendere degli esempi di
cose che già fanno a rotterdam fanno le
piazze d'acqua vengono chiamate quindi
trasforma una piastrina mente noi
facciamo cosa facciamo di solito su una
piazza c'è un bel parcheggio sotto
perché comoda noi dobbiamo andare a fare
il supermercato che a 200 metri
prendiamo la macchina no
gli anziani marchio con meno 25 vanno in
bicicletta quindi quando un italiano
dice non uso la bicicletta perché fa
freddo fa freddo in italia e quindi per
il comune di milano
la capacità è quella di ritornare a
lavorare sulle periferie e coniugare i
fattori multipli fattori di rischio in
un'unica risposta perché nell'esigenza è
anche questo e l'interdipendenza che
esiste tra i diversi settori sono in
termini portanti di quelli che sono
anche quei 24 anni che il pane tipo
andoresi che cita io a rocks ma
nell'altro pò cene e l'interdipendenza
dei diversi fattori
dobbiamo smettere l'uomo rompere i silos
in cui siamo chiusi ognuno di noi e la
nostra specializzazione e lavorare
insieme su diversi fattori
per che cosa vuol dire costruire la
resilienza dalla fine perché sono
partito dalla fine dalle soluzioni per
far vedere che la residenza è già in
essere
ne ha bisogno di farlo ad inventarsela
perché significa aumentare la capacità
di una comunità di sopravvivere
recuperare e prosperare in condizioni
economiche sociali e climatiche mutevoli
prima durante e dopo uno shock come
questo senso dobbiamo essere capaci di
prevenire ma di rispondere e rispondere
in tempi brevi
dobbiamo aspettare che succeda un'altra
volta come è successo di recente in
italia senza citare il regista le
diverse città e io passo vicentino ci
chiamò citiamo la mia e sono vicentina
proprio che la resilienza poi partner
banalmente da delle lievi delle funzioni
vitali che abbiamo fondamentali in un
territorio abbiamo le risorse idriche
meno risorse energetiche
abbiamo le infrastrutture le aree verdi
la mobilità urbana tutte le attività
produttive
la tutela della biodiversità la salute
il benessere e trasporti pubblici e
tutto in un'unica soluzione che la
residenza perché abbiamo una visione la
residenza non è mi hanno chiesto come
facciamo a cala reale esigenza ma
desenzano si cara è un seme che si
innesca una nuova capacità di vedere il
futuro e di vedere le interconnessioni
che esistono diversi aspetti della
nostra vita quotidiana perché in tutti
noi residenza perché gli elementi che
compongono la nostra società di oggi ci
sono dei rischi ai quali oa quello
doveva essere la premessa
oggi abbiamo in estate a rischio lo
definiva aurich back la società del
rischio che ha voluto mancare da poco e
se pensate a quelle a questi rischi che
ho messo qui sono gli stessi che ho
citato prima alla criminalità
organizzata
l'economia globale cambiamenti climatici
sociale l'alimentazione l'acqua e le
migrazioni
potrei citarvi altre esperienze di
resilienza abbiamo le si evidenzia nel
settore bancario sono i primi gr usano
le banche guarda caso e l'hanno fatto
dopo la crisi oggi hanno sostituito
l'altro giorno hanno inaugurato a
francoforte le autorità di vigilanza
sulle banche qualcosa che non esisteva
una cosa assolutamente positiva ma nella
nostra economia la nostra prima fonte
delle esigenze sono le piccole e medie
imprese
io sono quel tessuto che è capace di
innovare o un esempio meraviglioso mi è
rimasto impresso di treviso dove un
impreditore produceva pantaloni e te lo
diciamo in serie a questo arriva
ticinesi ha detto oddio adesso come
faccio io non voglio chiudersi messo a
pensare ha preso i vecchi telai e oggi
non produce più pantaloni in serie
intreccia tutela nei particolari fa
padroni che costano più sono di qualità
ea me sul proprio operaio veneti me lo
immagino e mezzo e adesso cosa faccio
non so mi sa come andare avanti la messa
davanti a un telaio gli ha detto per tre
giorni tu impari ad usarlo quello oggi è
capace da un telaio vecchio non usa più
il pulsantino ed è molto più contento
perché si sente anche più manuale più
capace è un recuperato a 50 anni ha
recuperato anche una funzione attivato
delle sue funzioni anche di pensiero e
da una persona felice in questo è perché
la resilienza cosa ci dici tu dici che
dietro ogni problema c'è un'opportunità
perché alla fine se ci pensate io penso
che dopo questo lo spera di trasmettervi
e che se ci pensate ognuno di voi e
resiliente ognuno di noi ha una capacità
residente al proprio interno perché alla
fine nella residenza siamo noi non sono
gli altri e tutti insieme possiamo dare
risposte a quelle che sono oggi i
problemi di un paese che affronta un
dato o stondato domenica inquietante che
però non è un problema è un'opportunità
abbiamo sei milioni di persone che
vivono in povertà assoluta in questo
paese è un dato istat non è un dato di
qualunque a questi sei milioni di
persone devo dare delle risposte e
queste risposte ha provato a mettere sms
al sistema possono essere una risposta a
uno di questi problemi autorità sulla
disoccupazione giovanile la questione 60
per cento dei giovani è disoccupato nel
sud italia senza andare a prendere la
quota delle donne che ancora peggio
in questo la residenza è una risposta
che possiamo dare alle crisi sistemica
cioè per farlo dobbiamo cominciare a
parlare con chi ci sta di fianco
chiedergli cosa fa ea quella persona
soprattutto sorridiamo perché anche
attraverso la felicità di precedenti
grazie